what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and today we have
a special guest who is back hi guys
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos guys i
see my analytics half of you don't
subscribe so if you've watched two or
more of my videos and you don't
subscribe we have beef
it's not cool right no it's not cool
guys you've got to subscribe it's free
it's freezing like what the freak is
free
okay okay
what up guys i'm in the kitchen where i
belong sorry to take this break from the
video but i have an ad for you studies
have shown that our appearance affects
our mental health who would have thought
the anti-aging industry has tried to
capitalize on this for decades oh no but
their serums and their supplements they
fall short
nasty and the reason for this is that
many of the products that are on shelves
in stores today they don't target the
source of the problem mostly they just
hide wrinkles using cheap ingredients
what the hey but i have an alternative
for you that's why i use multi-collagen
multi-collagen works to restore the
youthfulness of the skin honestly guys
between me and you it helps combat
wrinkles faster than anything i have
ever tried the reason being is that it
supercharges your skin's collagen intake
collagen is the protein our skin needs
to stay elastic these products right
here help deliver collagen directly to
your skin cells that's why it's so
effective imagine how good you'll look
this summer if you try it today get up
to 51 off by going to
healthwithpurley.com
or hear me out you can just visit the
link that's in the description
thanks guys back to the video
so today i'm going to be showing her
thomas sowell and the reason i'm showing
you thomas solo is because what was the
question you asked me earlier
oh she left free before once i forgot
we it came up we were talking about
economic and equality yeah and the
reasons behind it and you know i was
like you know what oh yeah instead of
explaining it i'm just gonna let her
hear it from the horse's mouth so
tell the people where they can find you
before we start all right then so i'm
active on instagram which is well my
instagram is ofc unscored zero nah
natasha and
that's it i mean it happened just this
week
a young person i'd never met introduced
himself to me and said that when he saw
our guest today
on an earlier episode of this program he
felt he was seeing a man who knew how to
think
dr thomas sowell on uncommon knowledge
now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to uncommon knowledge i'm peter
robinson
thomas sol has studied and taught
economics intellectual history and
social policy at institutions that
include cornell brandeis ucla and
amherst
now a senior fellow at the hoover
institution dr soul has published more
than a dozen books including the classic
a conflict of visions
coming soon a revised edition of his
most recent volume discrimination and
disparities
tom sol welcome thank you
you grew up in harlem dropped out of
high school to join the marine corps
during the korean war
received an undergraduate degree from
harvard
a master's from columbia
and your doctorate from the university
of chicago
all of which pales by comparison to the
fact that you once tried out for the
brooklyn dodgers
but during this period from harlem
to the university of chicago
throughout your 20s you've said you
spent most of the decade of your 20s as
a marxist yes
why what was it what what was the
attraction
well i guess i first
was uh
very puzzled see you there there's one
little question i would make
at age 16 i was a dropout
high school dropout
uh and i went to work full-time
as a western union messenger
uh
and uh delivering telegrams did
lorraine's halloween we better say that
because there will be a generation that
won't know what western union was
because yeah that's true too right uh
and so i i work i worked in the area
area of manhattan called the chelsea
district which is around 23rd street
9th avenue
and at the end of the day i had uh
several ways of getting back home like
the easiest and fastest way was was a
subway which was a nickel in those days
when i was feeling flush i might go for
a bus
for a dime
and then when i was really getting
reckless i would take the fifth avenue
bus which was the elite of the buses uh
fifth was 15 cents and so i would walk
over to fifth avenue take that bus
and it would take me up uh through all
the
glamorous parts of fifth avenue past the
empire state building
uh past the great
stores and things of that sort
uh and then on 57th street it would turn
this is just
the elite part of town sure right right
right right there where the park starts
yes and then and you
know park starts at 59th oh sorry 1557th
i would turn over it again the same kind
of scene past carnegie hall right
columbus circle there was no trump tower
at that time and uh on up to about 72nd
street and go out to swift
out to riverside drive which is another
elite area so for miles after that you
have all these wonderful luxury
apartment buildings and so on
and finally around 129th
or 30th street
uh it would go on a long viaduct
and then they would do a right turn back
into the occupied area and there you'd
see the tenements
and i would wonder why is this
i mean why why this huge disparity
and there was nobody else there was no
other other explanation around
there was nothing there was nothing
there other than marxism
uh i know i stumbled across i had not
read marks
but i i i bought a second-hand pair of
set of encyclopedias small set
for some ridiculously low price
and uh there they i looked up karl marx
i'd heard the name and the stuff that he
said
seemed to make sense
and later on i would get more and more
into it
uh and uh
the
argument was that the the rich had
gotten rich by taking from the poor
right
and well that was that was my
explanation but what was interesting
there was no other explanation out there
really have you ever heard that people
will blame the one percent
and say like the one the rich is getting
richer and the poor's getting poorer oh
my goodness
i've heard that
i heard that so interesting thing across
most of human history the majority
people have been poor
so poor is like the rule it's not the
exception like rich is the exception
so when they say
the rich are getting richer
like that's
the poor marketing port because we have
a higher standard of living ever than in
history there's just a bigger gap
but like even even people in poverty in
the us and i don't i haven't looked into
the stats here but even people in the us
that are technically in poverty they
have tvs
do you think in the 16 1700s they had
air conditioning and tvs if you were
poor no
that's like the rich people
yeah so it seems like the poor are
getting
richer it just throws a bigger gap
i'm going to have to actually go with
you in this one um it's like
with the poorer getting poorer it's more
so it's a sense of
we're getting rich abundant they're
already ripped yeah they've just got
their expenses so they're way up in the
sky yeah but then done
well according to the us that's the
actual the adversary the average poor
u.s citizen it's just that's that's
going like this but then
like with the rich people from the u.s
it's like they're going at that yeah
well and they're now this is a couple
years later so there is inflation which
is a problem in the u.s yeah so i do
think like we're about to hit a
recession so i do think like right now
the poor might get poorer but the what
the their way of thinking is that if
someone makes a ton of money they're
taking the money from someone else
no if someone's working for the money
they're working for them yeah yeah so so
we're gonna keep and that's true largely
in our college's university today but so
so by the time you went to harvard
undergrad well so
you drop out at the age of 16
and you start reading marks in your late
teens i know i started reading walks
yes 1949
at age 19. age 19. and then you were in
the marine corps for
a couple years what what was it two
three years
two years it's actually one
one year 11 months and five days but
who's counting
all right so by the time you went to
harvard
you had already become intellectually
engaged with marxism yes and remained
and harvard didn't talk you out of it
and colla and the study of economics at
harvard didn't talk you out of it nor
did getting a masters at columbia nor
did getting a doctorate
at chicago
dissuade you from marxism is that and
you studied with milton friedman of all
people how could you have sat in milton
friedman's classroom and remained a
marxist some people are just stubborn
but
what really changed me uh
was not the university of chicago uh uh
it was
my first job working in a professional
capacity of the government i was a
summer intern this is after chicago or
no no while i was still a graduate
student got it uh
and so during the summer vacation i
worked in the u.s department of labor
and i
began to realize from a number of things
that the government is not simply the
personification of the general will like
rousseau or others the government is an
institute the government institutions
have their own institutional uh
interests i want to involve the minimum
wage law i was a big supporter of that
but i also knew that there was an
argument that minimum wage law is simply
priced low wage workers out of a job
and uh my my first assignment was was
dealt with minimum wages in puerto rico
and as i looked at the numbers i would
see as they would jack up the minimum
wage
number of jobs would go down and so
forth
but there were two explanations one was
that of the economist that you priced
the people out of out of a job
and the other was that there are there
were
hurricanes that come through puerto rico
you see
during the
sugar harvesting and therefore i was
studying the sugar industry and
therefore it destroyed a lot of the crop
therefore you wouldn't hire as many
workers now chicago had been taught that
if there are two different theories
there should be somewhat some empirical
evidence in principle that could
distinguish what would happen under one
theory from what would happen under the
other right and so i wrestled with that
for the most of the summer and one
morning i came in and i said i got it
what we need are data on the amount of
sugar clean standing in the fields
before the hurricane struck
and as i waited for the congratulations
i could see stricken looks around me in
the room like this guy has stumbled on
something that will ruin us all
and they say well we don't have those
data i said oh i'll bet the department
of agriculture has it he said well well
but that doesn't mean we have it uh well
you'd have to have a request go up the
chain of command to the secretary of
labor he would then confer with the
secretary of agriculture it would come
down the chain of command and
the department of agriculture to whoever
has those numbers and so on i said good
well they say a journey of a thousand
miles begins with a single step so i
will now submit my request to the
secretary of labor which i did
and i am still patiently awaiting this
reply
so what do you think of what he was
talking about with minimum wage
stuck in my head was the whole
it's ever they are press workers or they
can't get as much workers and i feel
like i feel like what he said that tied
him with the minimum wage type of thing
i'm on the fence with minimum wage
because
minimum wage
of course going back to us that's of
course
it might be good for someone who's just
starting out the job but then
there's left
we people have a life to live people
can't be out here living on minimum wage
that's
blessed be realistic that's not going to
happen you're telling me i don't know
what's the minimum wage in the u.s um is
it three percent it's like 15. earned
eight maybe it's between eight and
fifteen depending on the safety point
oh my gosh oh no no no no no no oh my
god guys i'm saying sorry okay you're
not from the year i mean i think they
have a minimum wage here though don't
they yeah
our minimum wage isn't i think it's four
point e four pounds eighty oh really
yeah oh wow so it's lower than ours i
didn't know that that very much lower
but then let's be real people ain't
gonna live in the us they're not gonna
live on eight don't listen that wall
well the thing is um
it prices teenagers out of jobs
because who who's gonna take the eight
dollar an hour a teenager
we just want some extra like spending
money yeah
but then it comes down to what's going
on at home dude like parents can't help
because
they've got their own left hand well do
you know it actually some people argue
that one of the first minimum wage laws
was racist
in the us it was in california and they
did it um the number one group that was
affected
was um black teenagers
in the 60s
black teenagers in the 60s yeah so yeah
so because they were the ones getting
priced out of the job because they they
upped the income like how much they had
so
let's say um i hire i hire people here
right so like jess works for me now
let's say they doubled her wage and they
said you have to pay just double right i
would just
get rid of her it's sad i wouldn't want
to
but if i can't i can't afford to pay her
doubled of course yeah so because you've
got a lot to live at the end of the day
as well
exactly though the businesses have a
bottom line of course so that's that's a
lot of times when they raise the minimum
wage it
it um it gets people out of the job and
the problem is why
and and jess was happy working at the
hour she accepted because she wouldn't
have accepted the job if it wasn't a
good offer
so why does the government get to say
what job you can and can't take
hold on wait i'm not because i'm trying
to actually comprehend this what i'm
saying let's go back a bit yeah so let's
say you wanted to work for me of course
okay let's say you're 16
and you say i really really want this
job okay and i i and i say okay i'm
gonna give it to you for eight dollars
an hour i know it's not a lot that's
what we can afford and you you're so
excited you've always wanted to work on
a youtube channel i don't care
i'll take it right
then the government says no you must pay
her double or you must pay her 15 an
hour let's say
or 10 an hour whatever it is and i say
oh [ __ ] i can't afford that and you say
oh no i took it like
but the government says no you can't
legally hire her at that price
so then where does the job go nowhere
there's no job
but you were happy to take it because
you wouldn't have taken the job
if like if if it wasn't the best offer
you had
you know what i'm saying so if you don't
have a lot of skills and you need to get
skills
to get more money sometimes you have to
take a low-paying job in order to move
up
and so then there's a lot of then
there's unpaid internships right
but they could be paid if there wasn't a
minimum wage law a lot of the time wow
and they just can't afford what the
minimum you see what i'm saying no i get
it but then this is what california
right
yeah yeah well it's different it happens
all the time in the u.s but it just
depends on the state
so going back to what we were speaking
about earlier yeah so it was black
people that got affected by this so then
i'm not from you guys i'm not for me
it's not for me you can talk about my
accent yeah um so from what i'm thinking
it's like
was it a job where other races were
getting pizza and a mouse or was it just
black people well it was that kind of
pain it was it was it was like
economically black people were at the
like the lowest of the totem pole right
at the time right i think this is just
off of what i remember
but and so
the but how do you how do you move up
the next generation right
so let's say
yes
but i'm saying true but i'm saying the
way that black people as a community in
the u.s move up so say like say you
didn't maybe make it right you had kids
you never made a lot of money but you
want your kids to make a lot of money
right that's the next generation but
what happens is the 16 year old's trying
to get a job the businesses can't afford
to hire them and then what happens
they're on the streets
well is that good for any group of
people not because probably he needs the
crime yeah so teenagers with nothing to
do
yeah
what happens cram happens yeah and then
the whole oh let me know
and so it's funny because the
politicians will say oh i'm a nice
person and think they're doing good by
raising the minimum wage and they're
saying oh we're helping poor people but
they're not so they're patting
themselves on the back for hurting the
community
and this happens all the time once you
see it you can't unsee it
so let's let's hear it let's keep going
he might explain some of this later
institutional fear of the number was
what that
oh the us department of labor
administers the minimum wage law
and i and the uh money and the careers
of perhaps a third or some other
significant percentage of the member of
the labor department's resources come
from administering the minimum wage law
one of the real forces of all this is
that the law itself section 4-d i still
remember requires the labor department
to study the employment effects of
minimum wages and those studies are
absolutely a farce
in fact some years after i left i did an
article saying why those
those uh studies were a farce and when i
came back later on to the labor
department to do some research one of
the older librarians who remembered me
turned to the younger librarian and she
said this is the man who wrote that
article that has everybody up in arms
so you became you began to be dissuaded
about of marxism and of government of
government in general because the the
the government uh is not out there at
the personification of the national
interest right they have their own
interests and the labor department was
clearly an interest in
keeping the minimum wage because that's
that's their jobs and careers all right
and power in your which brings us if i
may to one of my favorite books your
2000 book this is a beat up old copy
this book conflict of vision yes which
you published in 2007 and you lay out
i'm sorry 1987. i beg your pardon
in 2007.
well beat up as this book is it turns
out this is the reprint sorry 1987
and you lay out two
competing ways of looking at economics
and policy really two competing ways of
looking at life that go back at least
200 years
the constrained vision
and the unconstrained vision
the constrained vision i'm quoting from
a conflict of visions sees the evils of
the world as deriving
from the limited and unhappy choices
available given the inherent
moral and intellectual limitations
of human beings close quote
so the constrained vision under itself
understands itself as constrained
by the limitations of reality itself yes
is that yeah that's correct yes okay
in other words they cannot proceed as so
many do that good things happen
automatically but bad things are
somebody's fault
got it got it and then do you understand
that
does that make sense to you the good
things happen they so this is assuming
that good things just happen and bad
things are someone's fault
so if you're poor it's somebody's fault
and if you're rich it just happened
you're not going to disagree with me no
well this is the vision that's what
that's the vision
that vision there's yo so you're telling
me because somebody's rich it just
happened because i'm poor at somebody's
fault no no let's be realistic with
ourselves this is life you're telling me
that i'm i'm quite unquote poor because
of what somebody did
i agree with that yeah it's live it's
not it's not somebody's fault it's
natural um natural causes
natural causes made me poor
it's not no uh because i'm poor
someone's fun because somebody's rich
that just happened so what you winning
the lottery just happened
i mean i feel like people in life make
choices which lead on to as to whether
they become poor or they become rich
yeah do you save your money do you spend
your money on drugs go on
exactly do you save your money do you
spend your money on drugs do you save
your money you spend your money on all
them new cars going from room life and
so many people just spend money like
it's water and then they have no wealth
over time they think you see how water
runs free different money runs free as
well
it don't run like that it really does
not run like that you can't save if you
want to be rich the idea that idealistic
ideology is you got to save your money
yeah that vision i really don't agree
with that vision strain vision
again
quoting from a conflict of visions
for the amelioration
improvement of the human condition the
constrained vision relies on
certain social processes such as moral
traditions the marketplace or families
not government
so explain that
why why do we rely why do we rely on
so on processes
rather than the will of the people
instituting changes to improve our
condition
well
it doesn't ignore government
uh
even for the market the work you have to
have a government as uh europe
discovered when the roman empire
collapsed and the economy has collapsed
also
uh
but i guess
one of the reasons would be that with
the government you have surrogate
decision makers and they cannot possibly
know as much as the individuals whose
personal decisions have been preempted
i see i see all right which brings us to
the unconstrained vision
when again i'm quoting you when rousseau
said that man is born free but
everywhere in chains
he expressed the essence of the
unconstrained vision which the in which
the fundamental problem is not nature or
man but institutions yes would you
explain that one well he has the notion
that uh again that that good things
happen naturally
uh if there are bad things it's because
uh institutions including civilization
itself have have made these bad things
happen
and of course uh and i think that that's
really uh the implicit assumption behind
a lot of things that are said on the
left today
uh and
why in my most recent book i go to a lot
of trouble to show that uh
in nature uh there's nothing resembling
equal opportunity that wherever you look
around the country around around the
world
uh
you find people who live up in the
mountains poor and backwards even in the
richest countries
including the united states
i believe the the poorest country in the
united states the county rather
uh was in a mountain community
uh which was almost 100 percent white
somewhere in appalachia west virginia
yeah uh and the men in that in that
county
i had a life expectancy 10 years less
than men
in a county in virginia
and the constrained the unconstrained
vision says let's fix that we surely we
can pass a law that would improve that
and the constrained vision says well now
wait a moment
if people who live in isolated pockets
and mountains are poor and backwards all
around the world and we see this pattern
over and over and over again maybe
there's something very deeply rooted in
reality about that
that's hard for us to get at correct yes
all right
so in the book a conflict of visions
you're very dispassionate and very
analytical
and you lay out the unconstrained vision
and you lay out the constrained vision
and you don't really come out blazing
in favor of one or the other no
yeah that is not a book meant to commit
to uh a show one vision
is better than the other it's there to
show you what what they are and what
you're assuming if you go one direction
or another okay and it's to encourage
people to understand the implicit
assumptions behind all this without
which you you're just
have you seen those two visions
i wouldn't say i have have you seen it
in people
so what i mean is remember like the
people that say the rich are getting
richer and the poor are getting poor
that's one vision right okay i've seen
that one then yeah
and then the other vision is like
it's all up to you and it's based on the
choices you make
and so it's not necessarily like if
someone's poor we can make a policy to
fix that because it has to be within the
community
okay i've seen the rich uh get rich on a
poor vision but the second one
is my ideology i don't i haven't seen it
but something that i don't think yeah so
do you think that's more common you're
from your parents are from africa right
yeah i found that's more common with
people from africa
because they're very much like i don't
know what part of africa are your
parents from um the southern base
so i don't know much about angola that's
right but but um like nigerians they're
very much work hard and it's up to you
and all your choices are your own no
yeah yeah yeah and i don't know if
angola is similar but i found that
people
that are like what i don't know
i feel like there's two types of ongoing
you beat the ones you're always working
in the laid back ones okay yeah so the
ones that do nothing and the ones that
work
well you've got two times yeah everyone
i meet from nigeria is like so smart and
they work so hard they do yeah but i i
don't know anything about aunt it's all
right
but i was just curious because i found
that people like that are actually from
africa like they just tend to work very
hard
did you say that's true
it depends on what bit but oh no
majority side yeah okay
it's a lot it loosely ends all right so
i should say that i meet in london then
i meet in london
pondering all this i i noticed something
a
column that you wrote this is a couple
of years ago in which you rebutted
nicholas kristoff of the new york times
and kristoff
had ascribed the gaps between african
americans and whites in america gaps in
wealth gaps in educational achieve the
usual gaps
to
and this is a quotation from christoph
to the lingering effects of slavery
close quote oh yeah and here's tom soul
quote
if we wanted to be serious
about
evidence we might compare where black
stood 100 years after the end of slavery
with where they stood after 30 years of
the liberal welfare state in other words
we could compare hard evidence on the
legacy of slavery with hard evidence on
the legacy of liberals close quote and
so there it is life is hard you use the
word hard
you use the word serious you use
evidence
tom soul
is a man of the constrained vision
through and through and through correct
yes
no no
uh yes you know
part of a
vanishing breed i might
so
when so when you were a marxist
the notion explain that because the mark
marxism
well but no no yeah so that's when i was
a marxist i had the same intellectual
standards right and that that's what
eventually led me away from it
oh i see in other words i did i hadn't
done all the research i hadn't gone
around the world
looking for evidence yes yes okay so
and so socialism is a great idea
that does not mean it's a great reality
one of the things that disturbs me
tremendously is about this enthusiasm
for bernie sanders do you know what
socialism is
yes socialism where oh my gosh i
actually love stuff in english and
you're like how many years ago hold on
yeah 12 11.
three to four years ago okay there's
socialism and then there's communism
okay socialism is um where
it's like it's equivalent to liberalism
where everyone's free how are the
quality of the doctors here
the doctor said that is a good question
um
it depends i feel like they were just
in terms of wanting to help people feel
like people are just there for jobs and
then other people are some people are
there for the pay because obviously
nhs was helping you to cover them 19.
some people there for the pay other
people are there to actually help people
get better and like stop cancer and
all of that so there's two types does it
take a while to get like in like how
does it work um because i guys so we're
in the uk
so i'm from the us so i haven't really
done much with that i've been pretty
healthy since i've been here that's a
good thing thank you god
i'm not gonna knock on wood but um my
friend went to the er and she said it
takes a really long time to like get in
and that's some of the problem when you
have something that's free is it ups the
weight times a lot of the time yep and
and so
i guess
even if you're seeing a specialist like
sometimes it takes a long time to get in
oh is that true
yeah it will take a shorter time
compared to like a actual hospital if
you're seeing a specialist
the time will be short off but you're
still going to be waiting okay like how
long usually i feel like in hospitals
i remember my sister was waiting for
like six hours just to get seen okay but
then if i you're seeing especially if
you want to see your special footage
you'll be waiting two to three hours max
okay so it's time for that actually yeah
but then in the actual hospital you'll
wait in definitely six hours okay
because we have issues too with our
health care system but what i've heard
and this is guys i know you guys are all
going to roast me in the comments
they'll be like why don't you know this
do your research
like look at i do it on camera
but um so
what i've heard is that the us has like
better quality so if you if you're like
have a really bad illness a lot of
people go to the u.s to get the
treatment but i've had that as well yeah
because here you might be waiting too
long if you have a specific treatment
and they might tell you that you don't
need a treatment even if you do because
the government gets to decide is that
right
yeah oh okay that is right yeah so if
i'm like dying and i say i need this
treatment and they say no you don't then
i'm just like
yeah and that's why no you're not wrong
with that you're not wrong
even it's not just the uk as well i've
read stories on many people from even
the philippines yeah many people from
the philippines they come to especially
florida to get their treatment it's not
just the uk like it happens all over yes
and it's maine i don't know why it's
mainly for florida but people mainly go
to florida in order to get the treatment
because the weather's there apparently
the um health um care is good there as
well guys i say apparently you haven't
been to florida i would love to go
but apparently it's really good there so
it's interesting because i guess when
you make health care free the problem is
like if i was going to make anything
free then more people use it even people
that don't need it oh yeah definitely
definitely yeah and so that's some of
the problem when when you have the
government make something free is that
sometimes the quality goes down because
they have so many people using it and
they're not getting paid out and it's
interesting because when they say
healthcare is a right
why why do you have the right for
someone to treat you
like why are you entitled just because
you exist for a doctor to go to medical
school for 15 years and treat you that
doesn't make sense
like what you're entitled to it and if
you decide to eat mcdonald's for 20
years why do i have to pay for your poor
decisions oh it's bank it's fine
actually finally
if i i work really hard to like stay in
shape and like run right and stop
roasting me in the comments i know
like i'm in shape okay
and yeah we play basketball but like why
if i if this someone else does nothing
like why why do i have to pay for them
when 20 years when they're in bad health
exactly and it comes to my mind and it's
like in my head there it's
every month for themselves everything
ever since i was younger i always had
the mindset every man for themselves for
example if you if you realize you're
obese and you're eating mcdonald's every
single day yeah and you choose to not do
something about to lose the weight
because you're gonna die and the doctors
have told you that you're gonna die the
specialists have told you you're gonna
die even your parents have said you're
gonna die but like have something not
clipped in your head just to start
jogging you know it's a government
requirement in the uk yeah
to run for 30 minutes a day at least do
some type of exercise but it means in a
day for the fact that you don't want to
do that why should i pay for your health
care if you don't care about your own
life
that's me wasting my money like no way
do your parents agree with you on this i
did not fix it no no my promise they're
not they're not the fit type
they're not the fit type
i'll be wrong they're not the fit type
okay okay let's keep going
and socialism at a time when people are
literally starving
in venezuela an oil-rich country
you know
and they're you know they're breaking
into the grocery stores to try to get
food and they're fleeing to neighboring
countries most of which are not all that
prosperous themselves but there but at
least you don't starve to death in them
uh and none of that makes a bit a bit of
difference
i don't think most of these people who
are out there cheering for bernie
sanders have given a thought to
venezuela
to the evidence that's right to the
evidence yeah all right
which brings us to
something that you refer to in a number
of columns you as the retrogression the
experience of african americans in this
country
economic progress i'm quoting you
despite the grand myth that black
economic progress began or accelerated
with the passage of the civil rights
laws and the war on poverty programs of
the 1960s the fact is that the poverty
rate among blacks
fell from 87 in 1940 to 47 in 1960
but over the next 20 years the poverty
rate among blacks fell another 18
percentage points this was just the
continuation of a previous economic
trend
but at a slower rate of progress it was
not
some grand deliverance close quote
that is so counter
to what we are taught in school what
appears on the editorial pages of
newspapers
that i have i feel as though i want to
ask you you really want to stick with
that
that is so i i i i have more evidence
than my more most recent book uh
discrimination and disparities
uh i point out that this really is a
pattern not particularly blacks or even
to the united states that you can see
the same thing in england you can see it
in any number of other countries that
the poor were or were much worse off
economically let's say on the first day
of the 20th century and yet
in terms of their own behavior
they were they were they had they were
far more decent
societies
uh
and and afterwards after after this
welfare state that's supposed to make
them better off and
better human beings that's when the
crime rate skyrocketed on both sides of
the atlantic
uh the british were
famous for being perhaps the most polite
considerate society in the world
prior to that
uh after that you get things like the
2011 riots over there between london
manchester where they were they're going
through this they they they
anticipated ferguson uh and
and uh baltimore
by a few years and the same thing is the
the burning down of buildings destroying
their gasoline bombs
the whole smear
uh and none of those people were
descendants of slaves
so so that
poor people were doing if the the lesson
of the 20th century is something like
poor people including in this country
african americans
were improving their lot and leading
fundamentally decent lives until the
government decided to help them yeah yes
that's a that's a fair statement
they're better off
economically because of what's been
given right but of course when you when
you have the crime rate
i mean i i got i got the first inkling
of this some years back when i was uh
at some school in harlem doing some
research
and i looked out the window and i
mentioned in passing that when i was a
little kid i used to walk my dog in that
park
and looks of horror came over the
students faces
nobody in his right mind would have a
child going to that part
walking a dog or not
the principal was warning these students
not to cross this park which is about a
block a half wide
uh even in groups of six
uh and when i and when i tell them about
how these hot summer nights i would
sleep out on the fire stakes in harlem
they looked at me like i was a man from
mars
people were doing that all over new york
they were doing it in philadelphia
washington wherever i've known people
that was a common thing for portland we
didn't have the money for air
conditioning right you slept out on the
fire escape or in the parks
where walter grew up in a walter
williams walter williams grew up in a uh
a housing project in philadelphia he was
saying on the hot summer nights the
people would be in this project have
little balconies they'd sleep out on the
balconies and the ones on the first
floor who didn't have balconies would
sleep out in the yard
and that they were old men who would you
could see sit on a hot summer night
sitting outdoors into the wee hours
playing cards or or checkers or whatever
it was a different world
infinitely safer now what about family
structure tom again i'm quoting you most
black children were being raised in two
parent families in 1960.
30 years after the liberal welfare state
the great majority of black children
were being raised by single parents yes
what
what's the
how does that by the way we should note
that
pat moynih patrick moynihan publishes
the moynihan report in 1965
and he's alarmed because the
illegitimacy rate among black families
is 25 then
now among whites it's over a third
hispanics it's over half and among
african americans it's over 70 percent
what's going on there
well this is again this too you find the
same thing in britain you find it in uh
france and norway you find it in the
western world
uh in fact uh the dissolution of the
family structure oh yeah there are any
number of uh western nations
where forty percent of the children are
uh are raised with with only one parent
right uh at the extremes
uh i i
to
asian countries uh at the extremes of
iceland it's uh two out of three
uh children born are raised in a single
parent home uh in south korea it's one
out of 66.
wow
wow
and so what
that's the welfare state what yes it is
you're paying you you're you're creating
a situation where if the uh first of all
well you're you're creating a situation
where if the man stays there the the
government will not give them give the
woman welfare
uh and if he leaves
it will and so they're paying they're
paying that when you pay people not to
get married more people don't get
married right right okay so so what
would have happened isn't that crazy no
it really is that's mind-boggling the
fact that it's true as well
yeah and it happened here too yeah that
is true because what incentive you're
rewarding people for bad behavior
and it's women a lot of the time because
we're leaving 70 to 80 of the time
in marriages
if they get married
yeah
and in in the u.s um
black women are the least married ever
it's like one in four will ever get
married
oh no
yeah and it's um but it's also like
eighteen percent of the
um
keep like the
18
of the guys in that community father 80
percent of the children
so it's like the men with multiple
kids wait so let me try let me set that
phrase again 18
of the black men in the community father
80 percent of the children
in the u.s
18 yes wow but it's the women because
they're picking men that already have
children
and they're just they're just becoming
baby baby mamas i don't know if it's the
same here
but
like in the u.s 70
like that's crazy no that's a that's a
high percentage and white it's it's
one-third that's not great either
because you're putting your kids at
every statistical disadvantage
there's a there's a
single
single mother or single parent to prison
pipeline
like the majority of people in prison
only had one parent
yeah quite really it does quite really
yeah i want to say it's similar in the
uk as well because when
this is i don't know like i said it's
not for everyone but for the majority
that come out of prison i'm going to
talk about malls right they talk about
how
their dad left there was so basically
you just think of the usual that dad
left it was only their mom because they
had no father figure they went to the
streets cause crime gang stuff
prison the cycle repeats all over again
well and here's the thing the laws
disproportionately affect men because a
lot of these kids these men they grow up
and they find out their mom their dad
wanted to be in their life but when the
mom and dad broke up the mom was being
petty yeah and wouldn't let him see the
kids and they're they don't have the
money to go fight for him in court and
the court system is against the man
yeah no the court system is definitely
against men yeah because i even where
was this already it was on some website
how the quote is is the quote is
subconsciously always with the woman
yeah and then with the men it's uh
i don't want to say the wrong percentage
because i'm actually speaking yeah i
think it's 70 to 80 percent of the time
the mom wins that's the yeah thank you
that's it yeah and the mom has to be a
terrible mother to lose custody like
terrible because statistically um kids
are better with their dad after the age
of like eight
do you think so yeah i feel like varies
no like overall and men are better
single mothers are worse off
economically than single fathers
so if they like single women own
two-thirds of consumer debt we're not
good with money and that's not good for
a kid like and a lot of times what i see
from single mothers is often times
they're spending on themselves it's not
their kids yeah it's the fake nails
that's like how much a month i like i've
seen so many baby mamas that have fake
nails
and they're and they're poor how can you
afford that i don't even get my nails
done
no that's why i'm thinking like
i feel like
this might sound like a hatred that's
coming from a woman myself it might
sound hateful but
seeing another woman
like leave wanting to leave the marriage
yeah just to win the court case for you
to not even spend the money on your
child
that that doesn't make me feel right
right and why do you deserve his money
you can get a job why are you entitled
to his money
they're rewarded for doing it is that
you know when then it goes back to
men are good my men are becoming more
broke because of this system already so
they're becoming more broke they're
gonna go into poverty poverty because
they've got nothing to do no job no
nothing no food to eat what are they
gonna do start stealing that's a crime
it's gonna lead to more crimes the law's
gonna catch up with them at one point
then they're gonna go to prison and the
prison and the sack was just going to
repeat itself like what the hell but it
all it all started with the government
paying single mothers
see that's when they went wrong yeah in
my opinion they went wrong and you see
it in the u.s and the uk no yes
definitely in the uk as well that's
where they went wrong
but it's i feel like it just i feel like
the government needs to be smart
because it's like some of us do benefit
from that yeah
but and then i feel like it's a case
where of the government to actually sit
down and he send someone over ask
questions and be like okay do you have a
job did you have a job is english your
first language did you come did you was
you born in the uk then they need to you
need to answer these type of questions
in order to actually find out should you
deserve that money or not not just give
it single-handedly because that's where
the problem runs so question do you
think that women would be more careful
with getting pregnant
if
they knew
that if they became a single mother the
government wasn't going to help them 100
percent so
do you think they'd maybe be careful
with who they slept with and get on
birth control of course yeah but most of
the girls that i know that
have either had an abortion or got like
pregnant they were very irresponsible
they weren't on birth control and no no
condom
so then you're pregnant but it's based
on your own your own choices
are not expensive guys so why do we have
to pay for their you're not pregnant i'm
not pregnant why does someone else have
why do we have to pay for their poor
decisions
because that's what is coming out it's
come out of our paycheck oh gosh you
have to say like because it's not
nothing's free
so it comes out of people that don't
make those decisions or paying for
people that make bad decisions
and then on top of that if the guy is
rich they know
they'll they'll be rewarded
and it's a cycle
i just want to tell everyone out there
that condoms are not that expensive
they're not that expensive it's okay
it's really okay to not have kids i
promise you you're not gonna die if you
don't have a child i just want to say
condoms are not that expensive we can't
afford one or they could have a kid with
a man who who wants a kid
instead of trying to trap a guy that
doesn't like them that's that even works
as well yeah because how often do you
see that where the girl wants like the
guy won't date her
and so she gets pregnant by him
i see that many times yeah but then if
it's reversed it's very awkward
that would yeah a girl can just have an
abortion if the reverse happens
i think they don't want that dude
if it's
they do oh my gosh you know um
40 of women who have abortions had one
or two before
oh wow
yeah i feel like that's quite high yeah
it's free here up to six months
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so i mean
that's actually the topic for the show
tonight it's actually yeah so we'll talk
a little more about those steps
it's like why do we have to pay for
their because that's also something
coming out of your paycheck they're
abortions
like
like for real why am i paying for your
irresponsible decision can you not learn
to be responsible like why do i have to
pay because of what you decided to do on
a random saturday night at 7 p.m while
i'm watching tv last year
yeah you don't think it was 2 a.m
it's a little early
no i i've heard i've had way too many
stuff at 7pm man
but it's it's like back to the
the government is funding bad decisions
yeah okay
if lyndon johnson instead of becoming a
liberal
had remained a crusty tough skeptical
texas texas conservative yes which is
certainly the way he started his career
if he if lyndon johnson had embraced the
constrained
vision
instead of instituting the war on
poverty and the great society and so
forth what would the country look like
today a lot better you would not have
the same rate for crime and so on
because you see you can't have a welfare
state in a democratic country unless you
first have a welfare state vision and
when you buy all the assumptions of that
vision
then you're buying a lot of trouble one
of the one of the episodes i think
epitomized it was in france in this case
uh that there were attached knife
attacks by various people from north
africa against chinese people in uh in
some suburbs of paris
and one of the
things that uh the attackers said you
know that uh why are you attacking the
chinese and it wasn't because anything
that chinese had done to them said they
have nice clothes and big cars
that's not fair
i mean
egalitarianism as a philosophy is one
thing but the actual consequences of it
are mean things like uh resenting other
people's good fortune right
all right so
one response to the gap
again i returned to this gap between
african-americans and other americans
affirmative action yes which brings us
back to your alma mater harvard
accordingly i'll never live it down
you'll never live it down yes
you once told me that the principal
benefit of a harvard degree was never
again having to be impressed by anybody
who had harvard degrees
absolutely
so
these are figures that were published in
the harvard crimson the student
newspaper and the harvard class of 2019
these are the kids who will be
graduating next june the average sat
score for black students was 21.49
by the way these are all good scores but
for black students 2149 white students
22 18
asian students 2 300.
well now that must be reasonable because
it's taking place at harvard the seat
of reason
wow well that wasn't quite how i
described it when i was there
affirmative action is that is that
we ought not to be doing this
no there are various uh
laws and policies that benefit one group
at the expense of another but i think
affirmative action has a distinction of
being one that harms everybody though in
different ways
and so you you there there's a lot of
evidence
that there are black kids who have all
the qualifications to be successful in
college who nevertheless are failures
because they are systematically
mismatched with institutions whose
standards they don't meet even though
they may meet the standards of 80 or 90
of the colleges in america
i remember first aware of this when i
was teaching at cornell
and i found that half the black students
at cornell were on some kind of academic
probation
and so i went over to the administration
building look up the sats of these
students the average black student at
cornell at that time scored at the 75th
percentile
which is pretty darn good yes
and so that means that
most colleges in this country they would
have no trouble and many of them would
be on the dean's list
but at cornell the average liberal arts
student at that time was in the 99th
percentile
and and when you when you when you're
teaching
students like that
you teach at a pace
that most people
of any race cannot keep up with
and i i was always complaining that i
was assigning all kinds of uh reading
but heck i'm teaching kids who are in
the top one percent they can make they
can keep up with it when they're reading
that i'm assigning
uh so cornell was taking very talented
black kids and spending four years
teaching them to feel inadequate yes
and succeeding at that
um do you guys have affirmative action
here so affirmative action is basically
when
a school or a company says there's not
enough minorities here
so there's not enough black people let's
say so in this case there wasn't enough
black people in harvard so they let
black people in just because they were
black
yeah
yeah i think we've got something like
that yeah
is it um
i think it was
a sixth form program our sixth form is
equivalent to
senior level of high school
so um
yeah it was for
seniors
and um
yeah basically all those who are of
african-american descent those who were
african descent or those who were um
what's the other one it wasn't european
caribbean that's it that's for african
and caribbean descent okay i don't even
know what it was you know because i said
i was not going to apply for that
program okay but it was i think it was a
program no that's it it was a program
for african and caribbeans to help them
get into uni okay
so basically the the issue with that is
that
you're putting people that don't deserve
a spot and you're giving them a spot
based on the color of their skin not how
smart they are
so it makes them feel dumb like in this
case harvard's one of the top
institutions in the in the in the us
right yeah okay okay
so
um and i don't know maybe you guys have
the london school of economics that's
really a good school here
i would say it is in my opinion okay so
if at the london school of economics
they said right now the
we only have five percent black students
and the population of london is 30
so we need it to be 30
they they would have to lower the scores
you would have yeah and and so people
that are really smart so let's let's say
they let you like no offense
i'm assuming both based on the school
we're both at we can't get into the
london school no yeah yeah so
okay so but if they let you in even
though you're smart and you do well at
our school you would feel dumb because
how would you keep up when everyone in
the room is smarter than you i'm not
trying to be funny i know it sounds
weird coming from a black female of
course yeah but letting someone in just
because of their skin color that's not
on because there's actually peace
there's some of us that we've worked
hard to get not even just black not even
just black people well just africans
caribbeans as well
like latinas south americans
some of us work hard in order to get
where we are no matter the race
and i think our pacific is not fair for
the fact that you're just letting me in
because of my skin color but say if i
got a good friend
you're not going to let her in this
world just because she's not african
caribbean descent that's where
well it should be based on that's where
rivalries come right it should just be
test scores that's simple test scores
right and and the thing is um asian
students would probably beat everybody
yeah they're small
yeah and it actually um asian students
will have an iq of 18 iq points below
another ethnicity and they outperform
them because that culture just values
education of course there are some
cultures such as value it more so they
of course are going to be a larger
percentage in colleges
so um
that's and it hurts everybody because it
hurts the black students because they
feel dumb they're not supposed to be
there even though they would succeed
somewhere else yeah
and it hurts the asian let's say the
asian students because they don't get
the spot
because they worked hard for it as well
yeah
i feel like it's not the smartest one
they definitely in the us too
and and the other problem
is so it hurts both like and then that
causes tension
because that's it because they feel like
they're getting their spots taken
you know what i mean so it hurts
everybody
and then the administrators who are
patting themselves on the back saying
wow i'm helping in diversity they're not
doing anything
you see what i'm saying like it's the
same pattern
it's the same ones with the people that
said oh we're helping poor people and
single mothers but they're not they're
incentivizing bad decisions they're
stuff then their subconscious their
subconscious is not working yeah their
subconscious is not working you're just
without realizing you're causing more
problems no now i'm gonna be the problem
so far i won't be the problem so far you
know what it's giving me vibes of it's
giving me vibes of the avengers like i
was telling you see if the avengers yeah
they think they're saving the world
right all you're doing is causing more
havoc and chaos you're just destroying
everything like what's going on that's
what it's giving me vibes of these um
examiners yeah oh no you know what i'm
not gonna laugh like i'm hoping the
situation no you're not i'm just making
everyone feel bad at the end of this day
you're not doing nothing you're just
destroying stuff like the avengers like
oh my gosh we're gonna watch like five
more minutes of it i'll go on go for it
this is these are both from the last
affirmative action case to reach the
supreme court last big affirmative
action case to reach the supreme court
2003 grudder versus bollinger
here's the majority opinion which was
written by justice sandra day o'connor
quote
the court expects that 25 years from now
the use of racial preferences will no
longer be necessary this upholding the
use of in a decision 5 4 decision
upholding the use of racial preferences
now that's quotation 1 here's quotation
2 justice thomas justice clarence thomas
so question what if there was white
quotas how do you think people would
perceive them
the majority
that's a good question like if there's
white affirmative action do you think
people would perceive them the same way
that's a good question i don't think
i'll be able to answer that i don't i
don't think they would i think people
would be mad at that yeah okay
let's keep watching in a dissent quote
i believe that blacks can achieve in
every avenue of american life
without the meddling of university
administrators
the court holds that racial
discrimination and admission should be
given another 25 years while i agree
that in 25 years these practices will be
illegal
they are illegal now
close quote
so
here's
what do you do with the argument that
justice o'connor writing that majority
opinion
there's something of the constrained
vision there look we have these all
universities across the country are
using these racial
preferences to as the basis of admission
the best we can hope to do is tell them
they ought not to be doing it that they
should be developing other standards and
give them a give them a clock
is that a reasonable thing to do
no but it's a universal thing to do i
wrote a book
about affirmative action because it was
called affirmative action around the
world and i made a couple of uh
international trips at the expense of
the hoover institution
around the world to check on affirmative
action this is one of the one of the
most common arguments that is absolutely
fallacious time and time again the
argument that
like so much in the unconstrained vision
it assumes that we have a power that we
do not have cannot have and never had to
have had yeah
in england there was a man named skarman
who was saying for the now we must do
this in order to order and in many
countries these pre these programs are
set up with an actual cutoff date
so it was set up with in malaysia with a
cut-off date i think of around it set
with 1990 and in pakistan it was like it
was supposed to go for 10 years
none of those
cut off dates has meant
a thing these programs not only continue
they increase they spread so the idea
that you can control for the future
because of these wonderful sounding
words
i can't think of a country in the world
where that say what happened
in the case of pakistan they did have an
actual
actual cut-off date
and because people in east pakistan were
for whatever historical reason way
behind the people in west pakistan and
so there's these preferences for east
pakistanis
now before time for this thing to expire
the east pakistanis uh cc from pakistan
and form a new nation of bangladesh
that's right and the preferences
continue right on because
there were other groups that had been
added to it and so once you get the
constituency you can't say no to them
wait that makes sense
so once they get the votes for doing
the affirmative action they can't take
it away because they'll lose the votes
so once you run down here one day so
once you give even with the single mom
thing like giving them money once you
win the votes of the single moms and you
give them money
from the government you can't take it
back on you no because then they won't
vote for you
and it's the same thing with
abortions up to six months it's the same
things with everything free that you get
once you give it to them you can't take
it like politicians aren't incentivized
to take it back
because why would they they got the vote
it got them elected
and then on top of that it's not them
that are paying for it
it's the middle class mostly yeah
so
they're they're in their mansions
i feel like the government just ruins
everything that's all i've got to say
the government
they ruin everything so
question
what did you think of thomas thought
there was a couple stuff i just didn't
agree on
oh what did you not agree
no i'm not that's totally saying that
but the other side yes i did because i
didn't agree with the other side yeah
and it was just like
the it's not helping like especially you
know what stuck to me the skin color
situation so you're telling me
i don't i i'll be so rad i couldn't care
if i was black even if i was white asian
i would still say this
i feel like it is wrong to accept
somebody just because of their skin
color because that's what causes
tensions that's to split into wars and
then that causes more mass destruction
that's you're not doing anything good
defend you think it's counteractive yeah
no i agree
and i think it's racist because it's
it's saying i don't think black people
can do it on their own
oh they need special privileges why
like do you think they're incompetent
do you see like do you see what i'm
saying like it's i think it's racist to
give the house out
and i i don't i don't think it's the
best i did i don't fix it like even if
he said what the top five percent right
yeah he said the top five percent was
the top five percent or students are
black
everyone else is over another race so we
want more black people
so what if the top five person are black
because in life there are factors you
don't know if someone probably dropped
out someone probably became a parent
someone probably just gave up on saudis
because it was too hard stuff happened
that top five percent of black people
they push through all the odds the same
way the other 95 of people regardless of
their race they pressure the odds too
you can't be now electing people just
because of their skin color because some
of us here regardless of my race i know
for a fact i'm a hard worker
like
i can work hard i know asians that work
hard you work hard
so just to accept people because of
their skin color
you're ruining it yeah it's stupid no
room in there so um
have did you learn anything new from
that video did it made you look at
things a little differently no i mean he
has it kind of makes a lot of sense
like with what you see in real life
right it kind of gives you a lot of
answers as to why certain things happen
doesn't it yeah because i always used to
wonder like how so many single moms were
so irresponsible
like i because i wouldn't i wouldn't
understand because they would have their
nails done they would have like all
these things that i don't even buy and
i'm like but you're buyers how do you
but it makes sense they're getting money
from the government
or from the baby dad
and then it goes back to what i said in
the last video as well i'm going to just
stop being angry at guys because i feel
like this system is just against men
yeah the system is just against men
because i can't even get
the system is just
against men men's money is getting taken
away yeah because their money is getting
taken they become poor they need they
need to they want to survive to you yeah
they start stealing from shops that's a
cram yeah the police is gonna know the
law's gonna catch up with them police is
gonna come find them
and it does
they disproportionately go to jail when
they're single mothers
because it's their kids and the and the
daughters become baby mamas
if there's not two parents in the home
that statistically puts kids at a
disadvantage of course and so it's it's
just interesting because once you see it
you cannot
okay guys um thank you so much for
coming on they they loved you so much
thank you so much guys
thank you so much you guys are the best
tell the people where they can find you
yeah guys you can find me on instagram
oh fc underscore 09 natasha i'm a very
nice person like
yeah
okay guys don't forget to subscribe to
the channel ring that notification bell
like the video on your way out and we
will talk to you next time bye